afternoon everyone I'm assistant sheriff
Chris Jones and I'm going to brief you
on some more details from the
officer-involved shooting that occurred
Monday night June 1st as I stated then
this is number nine for OIS --is in 2020
we have had four fatal so far at this
time last year we had also had nine
officer-involved shootings and at that
time we had had three fatal the shooting
occurred
June 1st 2020 at approximately 11:20 2
p.m. location of occurrence is 333 Las
Vegas Boulevard south the lloyd-george
federal courthouse located in downtown
Las Vegas at our downtown area command
you see that map to my left the officers
involved were sergeant Ryan Fryman
he is 40 years old and has been with LV
MPD since 2007 in this incident
sergeant Fryman was armed with a Glock
17 nine-millimeter equipped with a
tactical light and optics sight the
investigation revealed that he fired
seven rounds during the incident the
second officer was officer Daniel
Emerton he is 38 years of age he has
been with Las Vegas Metro police since
2006 in this incident Officer Emerton
was armed with a new frontier armory two
to three caliber rifle equipped with the
tact of the light an optic sight our
investigation revealed that he fired
four rounds during this incident third
officer is officer Vernon Ferguson he's
36 years old he's been with Las Vegas
Metro Police since 2006
this incident officer Ferguson was armed
with a Glock 34 nine-millimeter handgun
equipped with a tactical light and
optics sight the investigation revealed
that he fired three rounds during this
incident the last officer is officer
Andrew Loker he's 53 years old and has
been with Las Vegas metropolitan Police
Department since 1995
this incident he was armed with a colt
ar-15 rifle two to three caliber
it's the investigation revealed he fired
five rounds all of these officers are
assigned to our organizational
development Bureau range training staff
they are assigned to your Bureau that
does not require them to wear body worn
cameras they are not patrol officers and
therefore by policy they do not wear
body worn cameras as you're fully aware
over the last few nights we've had every
officer not only with our agency but
with partner agencies deployed as we
work through the events that are
occurring so these officers were brought
in from their normal duties to work the
streets that night we do have several
pieces of surveillance video from
various locations that we will show you
during this brief our suspects name is
Jorge Gomez Jorge is 20 was 25 years old
Hispanic male six foot 180 and he is
pictured to my left mr. Gomez was armed
with three firearms on this night the
first one was a Glock 23 40 caliber with
a carbine conversion kit you can see it
a picture to my left this is actually a
pistol that is inserted into a carbine
conversion kit that allows it to perform
like a rifle ii firearm that he was
armed with was a Glock 19
nine-millimeter handgun that was on his
holster on his side the third was a
Glock 17 nine-millimeter handgun that
was illegally concealed in a backpack
that he was wearing mr. Gomez was also
wearing a full body armor he had a
ballistics vest with ballistic plates
inserted into that vest
had mr. Gomez survived he would have
been charged with four counts of assault
with a deadly weapon on a protected
person as well as carrying a concealed
weapon during the course of this
investigation it was learned that mr.
Gomez had been present at multiple
protests throughout the week at each
protest in which mr. Gomez was observed
by police he was open carry displaying a
rifle and handguns mr. Gomez was seen by
multiple officers as he exercised his
right to open carry at times walking
only a few feet away from our officers
before June 1st mr. Gomez was not
suspected of committing any crimes
therefore he was not contacted nor
engaged by our officers on Monday June
1st 2020 officers assigned to the
protest on Las Vegas Boulevard and
Fremont notice mr. Gomez he was open
carry with a rifle conversion slung over
his shoulder and displayed a holster
handgun on his hip and a third pistol
which was concealed in his backpack mr.
Gomez walked back and forth on the
sidewalk and Street at Las Vegas
Boulevard in Fremont with a group of
demonstrators who were participating in
the protest due to the increased
violence a dispersal order was announced
over a loudspeaker warning protesters to
leave as the crowd was dispersing
officers lost sight of mr. Gomez
during this timeframe mr. Gomez left
Fremont Street and began to move
southbound towards the federal
courthouse a large crowd had assembled
in front of the federal courthouse to
protest George Floyd's death the
officers at the courthouse were notified
that some protesters were carrying
baseball bats at that time dispersal
order was given on loudspeakers and the
protesters began to leave the area of
the federal courthouse a second group of
officers arrived on Las Vegas Boulevard
to assist in the dispersal of that crowd
and these officers created a skirmish
line and begin to move south
Vegas Boulevard from the courthouse as
the protesters dispersed from the area
mr. gomez arise from the north side of
Las Vegas Boulevard and moved to the
front of the courthouse mr. gomez was
now behind the officers in the skirmish
line and we have some surveillance video
that will show this a little more
clearly I'll show that in just a moment
officers who were assigned to the
courthouse steps begin to move towards
mr. Gomez since he did not disperse
after the initial order was given one of
the officers noticed mr. Gomez and he
actually thought that he was carrying a
baseball bat as he was approaching the
area where the officers were that
baseball bat litter later turned out to
be obviously the rifle that he was
carrying this officer confronted mr.
Gomez and during that exchange the
officer fired five low lethal rounds at
mr. gomez fearing that he was going to
strike the officers with a baseball bat
mr. Gomez was struck with the beanbag
rounds and proceeded to run northbound
along Las Vegas Boulevard in front of
the courthouse
sergeant Fryman officer Emerton officer
Ferguson and Officer Loker were driving
southbound on the boulevard in route to
our downed officer call that it happened
moments before they saw mr. gomez and as
they exited their vehicles mr. Gomez
raised that rifle in their direction
these officers engaged mr. Gomez firing
several shots and striking him mr. Gomez
was transported to UMC trauma or he was
pronounced deceased will now be move
into some of these still photos and the
videos for those videos that have no
sound I'll give you a narration so that
you understand what's going on this is
mr. Gomez walking along Las Vegas
Boulevard in front of Planet Hollywood
and you'll notice that he walks past our
officers they do see him open carry and
if you look now they're turning around
watching him as he walks away he was not
doing anything illegal
therefore
or they did not engage mr. Gomez this
next video is from surveillance cameras
mounted on the building across the
street from the federal courthouse mr.
Gomez is encircled by the white circle
and you'll see him move toward the steps
he'll stop he'll have a conversation
with the officer at the top of the
stairs who was telling him to disperse
this is after the dispersal order was
given he'll exchange words with that
officer and there's other officers that
are stationed up there and to the left
here and you'll see him as they have
this exchange and the low lethal shots
are fired
it was him running back northbound in
front of the courthouse
those are low lethal rounds and that was
taken off social media and you can hear
the citizens saying he's got a gun and
then taking off Ronnie I'll take any
questions you may have
five five yes ma'am we do not we are
still looking for additional video as
you can imagine there were a number of
officers out there that night the
investigative team is still combing
through all of that video but at this
point we do not you heard it on the
video there just moments well I can tell
you obviously that he was armed with
three firearms he had a ballistic vest
on and there were indications through
the course of our investigation that
indicated us he was growing increasingly
increasingly radicalized we do not know
why we do not know all of his
perspectives we've talked to some family
members that have expressed some concern
about that but we're still learning
about mr. Gomez they were in fact the
the pistol that was inserted into the
carbine conversion kit the trigger was
disengaged which indicates to us that it
was pulled at some point however there
was an empty chamber so at some point he
did pull that trigger but whether he
knew it or not the chamber was empty
he is from Las Vegas as I understand it
he spent some time in Oregon as well one
more question and then I'm sorry he did
have one arrest for narcotics related
offenses I do not that officer has not
been interviewed yet one more question
for Miss Crosby no cut the we're still
interviewing those officers Shay was
shot a few miles down the road so I
would assume that they did not believe
that so that's all I could say right now
about that but it just I would assume
that they were aware of that so thank
you for coming out today and we'll send
more information out later thank you